Robert Spencer here for Jihad watch a
program of the David harwitz Freedom
Center and for the center for security
policy with new information about that
ever deadly pestilence
islamophobia islamophobia according to
the mainstream media is running rampant
in the hitherto bucolic town of oigo New
York and Muslims are worried are
marauding bands of right-wing extremists
pulling hijabs off little old Muslim
ladies and dobbing swastikas on the
walls of mosques no the islamophobia in
question appears on oo's new 9/11
Memorial monument which dares to refer
to the perpetrators of the September
11th 2001 Jihad Terror attacks as
Islamic
terrorists in this age of Obama o Wego
should have known better the local
station WWMT reported recently that the
monument was causing controversy as the
Islamic organization of the Southern
Tier in New York worries that the
wording could encourage hatred toward
Muslims living in the area painting all
Muslims with the same brush the Islamic
group has asked that the monument just
read terrorists or even Al-Qaeda
terrorists now calling the 9/11
hijackers Islamic terrorists is painting
all Muslims with the same brush this
isn't often used and very tired talking
point how does identifying the
motivating ideology of the 9/11 attack
paint all Muslims with the same brush
does referring to the Italian mafia
amount to calling all Italians mafiosi
does referring to German Nazis mean that
one is calling all Germans National
socialists this is just an attempt to
deflect attention away from the ideology
of the 9/11 hijackers and to keep people
ignorant and complacent regarding the
fact that those hijackers were working
from Islamic principles that are
embedded within the Islamic texts that
are read and studied and taught by the
Islamic organization of the Southern
Tier and this isn't by any means the
first time this kind of thing has
happened in April 2014 Muslim groups
protested against the screening of a
7-minute film entitled the rise of
al-Qaeda at the national September 11th
Memorial Museum in New York City shikh
Mustafa alazawi the Imam of Masjid
Manhattan complained the screening of
this film in its present state would
greatly offend our local Muslim
Believers as well as any foreign Muslim
visitor to the museum unsophisticated
visitors who do not understand the
difference between Al-Qaeda and Muslims
May Come Away with a prejudiced view of
Islam leading to antagonism and even
confrontation toward Muslim Believers
near the site now this was an
extraordinary complaint especially in
light of the fact that the film in no
way conflated Al-Qaeda with Muslims as a
whole all it did was use the words Jihad
and islamist nonetheless Akbar Ahmed a
noted Islamic scholar at American
University insisted that many visitors
to the museum were simply going to say
islamist means Muslims jihadist means
Muslims the terrorists need to be
condemned and remembered for what they
did but when you associate their
religion with what they did then you are
automatically including by association 1
and A2 billion people who had nothing to
do with these actions and who ultimately
the US would not want to unnecessarily
alienate that the terrorists themselves
were the ones who Associated their
religion with what they did not the 9/11
Memorial Museum Akbar akmed did not
address any more than did the Islamic
organization of the Southern Tier when
it was complaining about that 9/11
monument in oigo New York you may recall
that 9/11 hijacker Muhammad ATA reminded
himself in a note found in his suitcase
increase your mention of God's name the
best mention is reading the Quran all
Scholars agreed to this it is a enough
for us that the Quran is the word of the
creator of Heaven and Earth who we are
about to meet that sounds Islamic to me
ultimately the museum stood firm about
the film but it did remove the term
Islamic terrorism from its website what
a Wego New York will do about its
Monument remains to be seen but these
kinds of episodes are Illuminating even
to note the obvious fact that the 9/11
hijackers identified themselves as
Muslims and explained that they were
doing what they did because of Islam is
now supposedly offensive to other
Muslims and so it must not be done even
to take notice of the hijackers Islamic
self-identification is unacceptable
evidence of
islamophobia this is as ludicrous as it
is self-defeating that it has become
official Administration policy in
dealing with the Jihad threat and enough
of a cultural norm that the Islamic
organization of the Southern Tier wasn't
too embarrassed to protest against a
simple truth being told in oigo is
evidence of how severe the crisis we are
in really is I'm Robert Spencer